well it's like i i say this all the time
if if we had a song called i don't want
no whales i don't want no fatties
but
yeah
that was in response to no scrubs
but it's it's okay for every one example
you can name we can always name five ten
i can name i can go through cardi b
songs megan the stallion songs city
girls man great dancer but those songs
those songs are not really good for
women either which ones
cardi b and all the if a woman lived her
life like that
oh i i agree
i don't think i don't think it's good
advice
but at the end of the day it still
benefits women because it's saying you
can be as promiscuous as you want how
does that mean
the message is that you can be as
promiscuous as you want and still get a
husband at the end of it
and that's a message that benefits women
you can not cook you cannot clean and
you could still get male attention and
get a husband that's not even how these
girls live their lives like cardi b you
think she's not cooking and cleaning of
course
but
like it's not a good message to send to
women but like the point is the music is
still talking about something that
benefits women i just think when it
comes to music it's just purely
entertainment so a lot of things are
said more just for shock factor more
just
because when your daughter's twerking on
the floor or when your son's trying to
trap so yeah yeah it's not entertaining
when your door's twerking on the floor
i'm sorry
but that's the responsibility of parents
as parents for both the father and the
mother
for exposing their children how could
they how can you avoid it like the
average age of a kid seeing corn what
was it 11 12. yeah it's like with the
internet well it's not avoiding but it's
teaching your children at a young age
good morals and so like when i have kids
i'm not going to just blindfold them
throughout the world but you train them
and you prepare them well i just think
that's a lot easier said than done and
it's really hard to
like shield your kids from the culture
music has to be relatable in order for
it to resonate with the people that are
listening to it so
it comes from a real place most of the
time yeah it's not just entertainment if
if you can make a song called wap where
else [ __ ] yeah then there's a lot of
women out there
thinking and talking about their whap
yeah but right for it to bang just being
found
or for men
that want to hear that that men didn't
want to hear that
women back is not men didn't want to
hear that it's for women
is for women so who's coming to the
house the women go to a cardi b concert
and the mega standard concert and see if
what the majority of
men are i took i was watching
songwriting classes um off of youtube
and the guy said something um
about writing songs and one of his
advice is like the women that's your
audience so make sure the woman's the
victim in the song
oh good ballad come on yeah that's what
i'm saying it's always it's always the
woman well yeah because sometimes it
won't sound i mean based on how we use
it
based on how we see society wouldn't
benefit a man saying to the left to the
left get out of my house would it no but
put that on like a female that's like
neo said and you've got a banger and in
the day where they're going to be the
ones in the club singing our heart out
heartbroken or not because it's a song
lyrically have you not heard the new
dsvn tune dude yeah yeah yeah yeah i
heard that right now so dvsn have now
got a song called um
right
then the lyrics are if i get caught
cheating
that doesn't mean i don't love you
i'm sure you're not going to let one
little [ __ ] mess all this stuff up
right like that's the song and women are
losing their minds on twitter about this
song right
people are saying listen women have been
making songs like this about men taxes
these guys i mean that's the reality
though i think many women are angry
because we're being exposed for what we
take back but let's face it what he's
singing is what what men have been
saying to their woman for years and
years it's just reality what are you
singing is just reality it's just the
reality of what's going on this is
society at the end of the day yeah he we
just weren't able to say stuff like that
out in the open and it be actually
received you know what i mean the same
way as you said but it's being called
misogynist the backlash yeah people
instantly call it misogyny
did you say it is i said it oh you said
it why is that misogynistic
if i get caught cheating that doesn't
mean i don't don't love you how is that
because it is just the definition of not
loving someone how can you cheat on
women have different definitions of how
they love each other no no no no love is
no sacrifice for you but yeah that's
what you're you're looking at it you're
looking you're looking at it you're
looking at it from a female's point of
view i'm looking at it from who
so do men want to be cheated on them
it's not that they want to be it said
cheating's different for men and for
women because historically men wanted to
screw as many people as possible where
women had to find the highest quality
mate
and so we can't get undo our biology
just because society's different
today they have pretty much and so like
i've heard guys say they would have sex
with a hole in the wall that's what
you're saying right yeah guys have sex
hole in the wall and not know who's on
that
a girl they have to have something it's
a corn category isn't it yeah yeah like
like girls they have to have something
and it's like that's why men are the
major corn consumers yeah but if if
you're saying is different right and men
are the ones to do like men are to love
women right because if if you're in a
heterosexual relationship
and so women will receive are the
recipients of the love and so the way
that the man is loving the woman the
woman is telling you i am not feeling
that as love so it's like if i'm selling
something i'm gonna cater it to the
person who's the consumer so let's say
with the man and the woman the woman is
consuming that love and so you telling
me that the way i i love you i need you
though okay okay i'll break that down
for you okay okay so there's a man
loving a woman okay right the way a
woman receives love you said love for a
man and love for a woman is different
right because like a man it's his his
way of showing love is uh resources time
and attention where woman is loyalty
like okay we love in different ways his
way of showing it
doesn't mean it's going to be received
and if there's no point me like if i had
a business there's no point me showing
things that are not going to be received
well you can you can pick who you date
but often times girls pick the guy they
know cheats and then cry when he cheats
they have daddy issues
i don't think they have daddy issues
they just want they just want a very
small percentage of that
i mean even even so
sorry do you think that a manchin
instantly means that he doesn't love his
woman is that what you're saying
so if a man cheats with a woman he does
he no longer loves his woman
i would say he might love her but i
would say he's not he's not acting in
love he's not acting so what you're
saying is a man cheating on a woman
doesn't exactly equate to him not loving
her
at that very moment he's not acting in
love so i it depends on what you see
lovers
i see love is more as an action so so
what if a girl
what if a girl isn't giving her husband
sex
does she not love him
is she not acting i think if a woman is
deliberately not giving him no it's not
deliberately she just she just know she
doesn't feel like it well just
because remember because that's that's
how that's how that's how that's how men
receive love mine will be no no guys no
guys no one is going to marry a girl if
you don't wait do men receive love
through sex i thought it was women that
give
sex for love no they're more bonded
through sex but no man